[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, everyone.
My name is Andrew Wales.
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer on the Google
Analytics Developer
Relations Team.
And today I'm going to be
talking all about campaigns
and attribution for Android.
Just to give you look at the
agenda, so first I'm going to
talk a little bit about how
campaigns work generally in
Universal Analytics.
In our V2 SDKs, which is what
I'll be talking about today,
those are all built on top
of Universal Analytics.
So what's true for campaigns and
attributions generally in
Universal Analytics is
going to be true
for Android as well.
So we'll start there.
I'll then walk through how
Google Play Campaign
Measurement works.
This is really the main use case
for most people in doing
attribution on Android.
So tracking installs from Google
Play Store, and being
able to attribute those back
to campaigns or other
marketing efforts, et cetera.
So I'll walk through a little
bit, show you how that works.
I'll show you how to
implement that.
It's actually really simple.
I'll show you how you can
actually test it to make sure
it's working before you publish
your app, which is a
good thing always.
And then I'll also show you a
couple common issues that I
hear about a lot that you can
hopefully avoid by taking a
look at in this GDL.
And then thirdly I'll talk
about general campaign
measurement.
This is a little bit of a less
common use case, but it's for
cases where you have--
cases where you want to do
attribution after the app is
already installed.
So if you have deep links going
into your app, and you
want to be able to attribute the
opens of that app because
of those deep links back to
those sources, you can do that
with General Campaign
Management.
And I'll show you how
that works as well.
So let's jump right in.
So let's start with
campaigns and
Universal Analytics generally.
So it's probably, most of you
know, and this has been the
case for some time, there's
really five main campaign
dimensions.
And these are source, medium,
campaign, campaign, content,
and keyword.
And these five dimensions can
be used to sort of describe
any of your marketing
campaigns.
In this example, I'm showing you
like an AdWords campaign,
a CPC campaign.
But it could be used to track
marketing emails, or
newsletters, or links from your
website to Google Play
Store, whatever it is.
You can use these five
dimensions and give them
values that describe
the source.
So just a little primer
on how campaigns work
in Universal Analytics.
It's a little bit different
than how it was before.
So you can see here, you'll
see all these
gray dots on the bottom.
These represent sessions with
your application, or with your
website, whatever it is.
We're speaking broadly here.
So each of these dots here
represents one user
interaction with a site or an
app, and contains a bunch of
views, and events, and
e-commerce, and other things.
And we're looking at this
for given property
ID and client ID.
So the way this works is once
you send campaign information
to GA, it's going
to stay valid.
So every time I come back, and
as long as I have the same
property and client ID--
and by the way, this will also
be true for user ID when
that's available--
I'm going to keep having my
sessions attributed back to
this original campaign
information.
Until one of two
things happen.
Either there's new campaign
info received.
So if I click through
on another ad, for
example, and I come back.
Or if the campaign timeout
period expires.
So you can configure--
and I'll show you just in
a sec how to do this.
But you can configure at the
property level how long you
want campaign information
to stay valid.
So by default, it's
six months.
So if I clicked on an ad six
months ago, and I get up to
six months and a day, I'll show
up as direct after that
point, because the timeout's
been expired.
Now, you can change
that around.
So I'll show you that in
a sec how you do that.
So when one of those things
happens, that's when the
campaign information
stops being valid.
So for Android, which is what
we're talking about today,
what this really means
in practice is
that when you click--
suppose you track, for example,
an ad that drives
someone to Google Play Store,
that then downloads your app.
And that's the smiley face
mobile device right there.
What this means is that once you
get that original campaign
information in there, at the
time of install, all the
subsequent downstream user
activity, like screen views,
events, goals, and app revenue,
et cetera, all that's
going to get attributed back
to that original ad.
Until again, there's either
new campaign information
received, or that campaign
information times out.
Now, most of the time, unless
you're doing this general
campaign management where you
want to track deep links in
your app or something else, most
of the time you're only
ever going to really have that
install information.
So the original campaign
that drove the install.
And then the campaign
information is really not
going to change too much.
Furthermore, the client ID and
the property ID are going to
stay constant.
The client ID's generated at the
time that the SDK first--
basically when your app first
runs, we're going to generate
a random client ID.
So as long as the user doesn't
uninstall the app, you can
really expect that original
install information to be
constant all the way up until
whenever that campaign
information times out.
So with that, I just wanted to
show you really quickly how
you can configure that campaign
timeout period.
So by default, it's going
to be six months.
But if you want--
for example, if somebody
installs your app and keeps it
around for a year, for example,
if you still want
everything they're doing in
terms of events, goals,
e-commerce, et cetera,
everything after that six
month period, so six to 12
months, if you want all of
that information still
attributed back to that
original campaign, you should go
into your Property settings
and change this campaign
timeout.
And by the way, you'll only
see this campaign timeout
period if you have a Universal
Analytics enabled property.
So if you're already using
V2 of the SDKs, you
already have one.
So that shouldn't
be a problem.
Cool.
So now we've covered like a
little bit about how campaigns
work in Universal Analytics
in general.
And what that's going
to mean for Android.
I'm going to show you a little
bit about how Google Play
Campaign Measurement works.
It's actually pretty simple.
So the way it's going to work
is that any ads or marketing
efforts that you have you can
link to Google Play from those
things, but you're going to link
to your app's download
page, for your app's-- whatever
page on Google Play
Store with the Download
button.
And you attach this
refer parameter.
And as the value of that
parameter, it's going to be a
URL encoded string of
these UTM tags.
UTM source, UTM media, and
term, content, campaign.
And these all equate to
those five dimensions
I showed you earlier.
And that's going to send the
user to your apps page on
Google Play Store.
So in this example, I'm
showing Google Drive.
What happens from there, if they
choose to install the app
right then, what happens there
is that the Google Play Store
app on the device is going
to broadcast this
install refer intent.
And as part of that refer
intent, it's going to grab
that refer parameter, the value
of it, from the link
that you used to send
people there.
And it's going to include that
as a string extra in that
bundle with the intent.
The way this normally works
if you do a standard GA
implementation is that
you'll have a
Analytics Broadcast Receiver.
And I'll show you how to
implement that in a second.
And that's going to be able to
receive that intent, and it's
going to store that
refer information.
And then when the app actually
runs, the SDK is going to send
that out with the first
hit that's dispatched.
And that's how your campaign
information is going to get
back to GA.
And then everything that the
user does from then on is
going to be attributed back to
that original campaign source.
Whatever was in that
refer parameter.
So you'll see in your Google
Play sources, this
is kind of a look.
You'll see something that looks
like this, where you
have the source and medium,
and you have your new user
sessions, duration.
All the metrics and dimensions
and stuff you want to use will
be available there.
So really quick.
There's basically four
steps to doing
implementation on this.
And it's pretty straightforward.
First, obviously you
need to add the
Analytics SDK to your project.
Then you need to add this
GA Broadcast Receiver.
This is optional really, but
it's a good idea to test the
implementation just to
make sure it works.
A lot of times, if it doesn't
work and you push the app to
Google Play store, then you've
got to push it all over again
just to start getting campaign
information.
And that's a pain.
So it's good to test.
And then four, to generate
your Google Play URLs.
So the URLs you're going to be
using to send people to your
apps page on Google Play.
So to add the Analytics SDK,
it's pretty straightforward.
I'll show you really quickly
just an example.
I use the note pad example.
So if you have the Android SDK
installed, you should be able
to create this sample
app as well.
If you want to do a really
basic Analytics
implementation, it's pretty
straightforward.
You just need to go ahead and
create a folder called Libs,
and add this, our JAR file.
The Analytics V2 JAR file.
At that point, you can go in
and you basically just tag,
sort of just like you
would on the web.
So in this example, I have the
notes list, and also the note
editor activities I tagged with
just these simple tags.
So you can see overriding the on
start and on stop methods,
and adding the Easy Tacker
activity start and activity
stop methods.
So you'd want to do that across
all activities that
you're using.
And that's probably the most
basically way to install, to
implement GA.
Of course, you can make
it much more complex.
But just for the sake of this
example, that's all you need
to do is the bare minimum.
And then the next step, just to
be sure, you want to make
sure you have the permissions in
your Android manifest file
to use the internet and access
the network state.
And then also, the nice thing
about Easy Tracker is that you
can create this Analytics
XML file.
And here you can manage all your
configuration settings.
So your property ID, whether
or not you want to do auto
activity tracking, turning on
and off debug mode, et cetera.
So that's just a really
basic implementation.
Obviously, you can do a much
more advanced one.
But I just wanted to give you
a quick sense of what that
would look like.
So once the SDK is implemented,
however you're
going to do that, the next step
is to make sure that the
Broadcast Receiver actually
gets implemented as well.
And this is going to be the
receiver that takes that
install refer intent that the
Google Play Store is going to
send to your app.
So really quickly, what that's
going to look like.
If we go to the Android manifest
file, you can see
I've already added it here.
And you can get this from the
developer site, or it's in the
Java doc as well.
But basically, it's a service
and a receiver.
And what the service is going
to do is when that install
refer intent comes through, the
service is actually going
to write that refer information
to a file.
And then when the app actually
is running and fully
installed, the SDK is going
to read from that
file and send it.
Whatever information's there,
if any, with the first hit.
So that's it.
So just copy and pasting this
receiver and the service into
your Android manifest file.
And then, technically, you
should be good to go.
Unless you have a more advance
implementation, which we'll go
into in a sec, you should be
able to receive that intent,
and the SDK should be able
to read it and send
it with hits .
Let me just show you a blown
up view, just in case you
couldn't see it on my screen.
And again, this is available on
the developer site, so if
you go to developers.googl
e.com/analytics, and go to
Android, you'll be able to get
this in our campaigns dev
guide there.
So the next step would be
testing the implementation.
This, again, is always
a good idea to
make sure it's working.
Again, you don't want to have to
push your application twice
to Google Play Store
just to get the
campaign measurement working.
So I'm going to show you one way
to test to make sure this
is working.
What it's going to do is
basically you're going to
broadcast that install refer
intent to your application
from the Android Debug Bridge
command line tool.
And you can include the refer
extra, and you can give it
some sample UTM parameters
and values.
And then you can just see if you
can run your application
and make sure--
because it will print it to logs
whether or not it found
campaign information.
So you can use this process to
make sure that the receiver's
properly configured, that it's
going to receive that intent,
and that the SDK is picking up
the campaign information
that's there.
So there's basically three
steps to this.
First one is once you're ready
to test, you want to install
your application on the device
that you're using to test.
So it could be an emulator,
or it could
be a connected device.
Yeah, and it's a pretty
simple command.
You just use whatever your path
to ADB is, the Android
Debug Bridge.
I think for most people, they
have a SIM link, so it's
usually ADB install, and then
the path to your APK file.
Step two is make sure the
app isn't running.
That causes problems with the
way that the Google Play
Broadcast Receiver and service
are designed to work.
So just make sure the
app isn't running.
Just install it, but don't
actually open it.
And then the third is we're
actually going to broadcast
the intent.
So again, it's kind
of the same thing.
You're going to have
your path to ADB.
When you broadcast the intent,
you have to specify your
package name, and also the
path to the receiver.
Then you tack on this string
extra that's named refer.
And then you can add your UTM
parameters and values.
You don't really need
to do too much here.
You can actually just
do UTM source equals
whatever value you want.
That's really the only
required field.
And that's good enough for
the purposes of testing.
And when you're going to be able
to see in logs is that if
the campaign information's
found, you see a
message like this.
So you'll see GA, the SDK
spitting things out to logs.
And one of those things is going
to say Campaign Found.
I'll say UTM source, and it
should have the value that you
broadcast to it.
If it does not say Campaign
Found, it'll say
Campaign Not Found.
And if that's the case, it's
usually either a problem with
the receiver.
It may not be implemented,
or it's
not implemented correctly.
You might have multiple
receivers.
And I'll talk about
that in a second.
So with the install refer
intent, you can actually only
receive it in one Broadcast
Receiver.
So if you already have one, and
then you try to paste the
Analytics Receiver in, the
Analytics Receiver might not
actually get called
in that case.
Or the broadcast wasn't
actually successful.
So you'd want to go back and
just make sure that you're
actually seeing--
ADB will tell you that
the broadcast was
successfully done.
So you should go back and
double check that.
So that's the first
three steps.
You've implemented the
Analytics SDK.
You've added the Broadcast
Receiver.
You've tested the
implementation.
So hopefully, everything
looks good there.
And then the last step
is just to generate
those Google Play URLs.
And this is really easy to do.
Again, the format is basically,
it's going to be
the link to your apps' Google
Play Store page.
So it's Google Play Store, and
then you have as ID equals
your package name.
And then you're going to have
this refer parameter.
And the value of that refer
parameter is going to be a URL
encoded campaign parameter
string.
So a string of these UTM source
equals whatever UTM
medium equals test
medim, et cetera.
All separated by ampersands.
We actually have a tool on
the developer site, so
developers.googl
e.com/analytics.
If you go to the campaign dev
guide for Android, we have a
Google Play URL builder.
So you can just pop in your
package name, the campaign
source, medium term,
content, et cetera.
And we'll generate
that URL for you.
And just so you know, if
you're using AdWords or
DoubleClick and you have these
click IDs, like gclid or
dclid, you can pass those
values as well
in that refer parameter.
So you just enable auto tagging,
for example, for
AdWords, and send users
to Google Play Store.
And that should be sufficient.
And then the SDK is able to pick
up on that click ID, and
then we'll join it with the ads
data, so we can bring in
your campaign term, et cetera,
all automatically.
Cool.
So that's basically it.
It's a pretty straightforward
implementation.
You can test it, and we have the
tools to help you generate
the Google Play URLs as well.
So next I want to talk about
two common issues.
One of which is that people
oftentimes will see more
sessions attributed to
direct/none, so source direct
medium none than they expect.
And to be sure, you're
definitely going to see a lot.
It might even be the most,
like the top source.
For you, that may be normal.
It may be that everything's
working as expected.
But one reason why it might be
higher than you expect--
this is just a view of
what that would look
like in your reports.
One reason why it might be
higher is because of the way
that the Google Play Store app
works in terms of that URL and
the refer parameter.
So if we go back to this example
where you drive from
an ad, via that link with the
refer parameter, to the apps
page on Google Play Store.
As long as they choose to
download right from there,
it'll be fine.
And that refer parameter will
get bundled up and sent off
with that intent,
and everything
works as I just described.
The tricky part comes when
people, actually, if users
move away from that page.
For example, if they go out to
the Google Play homepage, and
then they navigate back to your
app download page and
then install, the refer
information is
gone at that point.
So that install is going to be
attributed to direct/none.
And that's just kind of the way
it works on Google Play
Store at the moment.
So you're only ever going to get
campaign information for
those users who follow one of
your links that's tagged, land
on Google Play, and then
download right there.
If they do anything else, if
they navigate around Google
Play Store, that refer
information gets lost.
We don't keep it with them
and then send it
on when they download.
So that's usually the main
reason why you see more
direct/none than you
might expect.
But with that said, for most
people, as far as I've seen,
direct/none is usually
the top.
So usually most people are
discovering the application by
going directly, or they already
know what it's called.
So it's not unusual to see that
at the top, but this is
one reason why it might be
higher than you expect.
Another common issue, the second
one that I alluded to
earlier, is when you have
multiple receivers that are
all trying to receive that
install refer intent.
So the thing about that intent
is that it can only be
received by one Broadcast
Receiver.
So you want to make sure that
you don't run into the
situation where you already
have, for example here, you
already have some receiver
that's receiving that install
refer intent and doing
some work with it.
And then you just copy
and paste in the
Google Analytics receiver.
And this will either not work
or it won't work reliably.
Because again, only one of these
is going to get called.
So the solution for this, it's
pretty straightforward.
Sad face icon.
You don't want to do this.
What you want to do instead
is, at least in the last
example, you would take the
receiver that you already had,
and you do whatever work you're
going to do with the
install refer intent, right?
And then at the end, as soon
as you're done with all the
work that you're going to do
otherwise, you can just
instantiate this Google Campaign
Tracking receiver, so
it's just
campaigntrackingreceiver.
You can call, it's on receive,
and then pass it the context
and intent.
So you're just doing--
you're not adding a new receiver
to your Android
manifest file, you're just going
to take what you already
have, and then when you're
done with whatever you're
doing with that intent, just
instantiate the GA receiver.
And pass call on receive,
and pass it the intent.
And that will be good enough.
Yep, and that's exactly
what you want to do.
So at this point, you should
know how to implement Google
Play campaign measurement.
You implement it with the
Broadcast Receiver.
You can test it.
Know how to generate the
Google Play URLs.
And the two things you want to
avoid are forgetting that if
people move around Google Play
Store, that their refer
information is lost.
And that's just the way
it works currently.
And then, two, that if you
already have a receiver,
you'll want to do go ahead and
just make sure you instantiate
the GA and receiver as
part of the work that
your receiver does.
Rather than registering both
and having them called
inconsistently.
So we have a couple resources
that I recommend everybody
check out if they have more
questions about this.
Or if you're going to do an
implementation and you want to
have some documentation
next to you.
The first is our Campaign
Measurement Developer Guide.
So that's at the
developer site.
And if you'll just look on the
left nav, it will be under the
Android SDK, and
then Campaigns.
We also have that Google Play
URL Builder, and that tool's
actually embedded into the
campaign dev guide as well.
And then we also recently just
published a testing guide, so
you'll see all of the ADB
commands that I just used.
We published all
those as well.
So it's in our Solution
section.
So you can go check that out,
and you should have everything
you need to implement
and test.
So that's Google Play Campaign
Measurement.
That's the primary use
case for doing
attribution on Android.
But I did want to talk just
really briefly about general
campaign management.
So this would be, again, for
cases where you have some
intent that's opening
up your application.
Maybe you're deep
linking into it.
Maybe it's some other app.
Whatever it is, you have some
intent that's opening your
application after it's already
been installed.
And you want to be able to
do attribution there.
So that's what General Campaign
Measurement is for.
And just to show you a quick
example of how this works,
there's a helper method in the
tracker class that's called
Set Campaign.
And Set Campaign basically just
takes a string of those
campaign parameters, so UTM
source, UTM medium, all of
that stuff.
So if you can get that parameter
string into your
application--
again, it's usually via some
intent-- you can just pass it
to that tracker.
Set campaign, and if it's valid,
we'll set that new
campaign information.
And the next hit that goes out
will include that campaign
information.
And then that session and any
subsequent sessions, will be
attributed to that new
campaign information.
So this example is just a really
quick demonstration of
how you could do this in
a sample activity.
So basically, you just
get the intent
that started the activity.
You get the URI from
the intent.
And then you can just check to
see-- again, UTM source is the
only required parameter.
So you could just check to see
if UTM source is present in
that URI or not.
And if it is present, you can
assume that there's valid
campaign information there.
So you can just get your
tracker, if you already use
EasyTracker, the gettracker
method of EasyTracker.
But if you have a reference to
your tracker any other way,
you can do that.
And then set campaign, and then
you just pass it, that
string of campaign parameters.
And just to show you what's
going to happen, to return to
this slide.
What will have happened is that
you will have-- up until
that point, all the sessions
that the user had in that
application will be attributed
to whatever was sent through
at install time.
And then as soon as you do that
next attribution step, so
if it's a deep link or whatever
else, as soon as you
call set campaign and then
send a hit, all of that
session and any subsequent
sessions will be tagged with
that new source.
So that does mean that if you
do this, for example, if you
tagged a deep link, and then
you set the campaign
information that way, it means
their subsequent activity, if
it's e-commerce or events or
whatever, are now going to be
attributed to that new source.
And you won't have that
attribution back to the
original install source.
So it's just something
to be aware.
Usually that's what you want,
but just so you know, you
won't have access--
there is no install campaign
dimension where you can always
see back to whatever the
original install campaign was.
Cool.
That's pretty much it.
So we talked about
a couple things.
Google Play Campaign
Measurement, how to implement
it and test it.
Generator those URLs.
Some common pitfalls to avoid.
Then also, the second use case,
mainly for Android, is
that general campaign
measurement,
which I showed you.
Which you can do really
easily with that set
tracker helper method.
And that should cover most
cases for doing Android
attribution and campaigns.
Let me just check to
see if we have any
questions on the Dory.
OK.
Well, if you guys have any
questions, you can always
catch me on G+.
You do g+.2/AWales and
that will take
your right to my page.
And I hope to see you around
on the next Analytics Live.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]